You know Maya Angelou
was a mentor for me,
and when she was invited
to write the inaugural poem,
as I shared with you,
for President Clinton,
I sent her the coat and gloves
and she wore them
so beautifully.
And I wanted to continue
that tradition,
but you'd already chosen
your fabulous coat...
- Amanda: Yes.
- ...that's now gone viral
along with your red headband.
So I sent you the ring,
a caged bird,
paying tribute to Maya,
for that seminal book of hers.
Do you feel like the baton
of those who came before you
has been passed down
to and through you?
Oh, that's a great question,
and it meant so much to me
to have my own piece of Maya
with me in that moment
because as I mentioned,
when I told myself
every time I wrote a poem
to write a poem worthy
of an inauguration,
I would listen to Maya's poem.
I would listen to
"On The Pulse Of Morning"
probably every single morning
of my last year of college.
So it was great to kind of
exist in that same space
in the inauguration.
And when I think--
I'll stop you right there.
Let me stop you right there.
Why were you listening
to her poetry
from the inauguration?
Why were you listening
to "On The Pulse Of Morning,"
which was her inaugural poem?
Why were you listening
to that every morning
your last year of college?
I would listen
to Maya's poem so often
just because for me
I was in a deep place
where I was trying to
analyze the power of poetry
to speak for a people
and speak for a populace,
and to do so with hope.
And having Maya's poem
as an example
not only of written word
but also incredible spoken word
that she brought to it,
I wanted to continue
to participate
in that tradition
of hope-making
in every single poem
that I wrote.
So that's how I grounded
myself every morning.
And I've read that you
so related to Maya's story
also growing up because
of the loss of her voice
and your being able
to incorporate
what she was able to do
with you really retraining
yourself how to speak.
When I first heard that,
I went, "Well, whoa.
That is just a miracle."
It was an amazing discovery
when I was reading
"I Know Why
The Caged Bird Sings,"
her autobiography.
And reading about
her issues with speech,
I almost was kind of angry
with every single educator
that I'd encountered
up to that point.
I was like, I'm a black girl
with a speech impediment,
and no one thought
it was relevant to tell me
that this great orator
that I'm reading
had a similar struggle?
So being able to connect
with her and relate with that
was a real beacon for me
in my life.
It's so difficult to be
that which you cannot see,
to dream that which
not has become itself yet,
and so I really looked to her
for inspiration.